quand je vais vous parler d'une
initiative qui à mon avis va vous faire
plaisir jérémy c'est une initiative
plutôt sympathique entre des collégiens
et un liquoriste et là vous allez me
dire il n'ya pas le collégien sur son
plateau détrompez vous détrompez vous
chez marie christine been you lie qui
est principale adjointe au collège de
nuits-saint-georges donc à côté de dijon
vous savez travailler avec une classe on
les voit ici de dos avec quelle classe
avez vous travaillé avec une classe la
6e 7 qui est une classe composée de 22
élèves et alors qu'elle est cette idée
lumineuse que vous avez eus ar c'est une
idée qui est née en fait d'une
discussion avec un enseignant pour
pouvoir rapprocher le monde de
l'entreprise et donner du sens aux
apprentissages avec les enfants donc
nous sommes dit quel projet pourrions
nous imaginer comment pourrions nous
retrouver une un partenaire local qu'on
puisse faire découvrir à une classe et
puis qui emporte l'adhésion et surtout
qui soit porteuse de sens pour qu'ils
comprennent que toutes les compétences
qui sont en train de travailler
eh bien ils vont les retrouver dans leur
vie future alors ce projet
marie-christine bignolas et quoi
précisément alors ce projet c'est en
fait répondre à la problématique
suivante inventer un nouveau siro pour
demain pour l'entreprise vedrenne qui
est notre partenaire
d'accord elle est juste à côté de vous
c'est vrai que vous avez construire le
projet ensemble
si josé gil ensemble c'est mieux nous ça
nous va bien un peu lundi au vendredi
avant le 12 13
quel est l'intérêt finalement pour votre
société société que vous représentez le
liquoriste vedrenne de s'intéresser à
cette initiative de collégiens pour nous
c'est très important parce que ça permet
d'ouvrir l'entreprise la communauté
locale donc
nos différentes personnes qui
travaillent dans l'entreprise vont être
amenés à témoigner de leur métier auprès
la classe de sixième donc c'est aussi
avoir un projet commun aux sarments
entreprises et partager nos valeurs au
niveau local une très heureux de
travailler en partenariat avec alors au
delà du fait que tout le monde soit très
heureux ça j'ai compris sur le projet
pédagogique j'y reviens parce que c'est
ce qui nous intéresse à des parents et
des grands parents qui sont avec nous on
se dit ça veut dire que vous avez voulu
donner du sens à des enseignements
théoriques comme celle les enfants voilà
ils comprennent c'est ça oui en fait
très très concrètement comment les
mathématiques comment l'anglais on
avance on sait voilà peuvent être
réinvestis dans un projet est porteur de
sens donc là par exemple les
pourcentages et bien on va les calculs
et pour trouver saunier nouveau siro
c'est génial seulement le prof de maths
il va s'intéresser aux pourcentages et
d'un coup d'un seul ça va les intéresser
parce que autant ils peuvent s'en fiche
un petit peu des trucs très traditionnel
là le sirop vous le disait fort
justement tout le monde en bois les
jeunes particulièrement donc là ça y est
ça éveille chez lui c'est le sait
d'autant plus porteur de sens que ses
enfants ont 10 11 ans qu'ils aiment le
sirop donc c'est quelque chose un
matériau qu'ils connaissent et ce sont
des goûts ce que c'est vraiment un
produit qui leur parle et de le relancer
à des filles comme ça voilà inventé le
nouveau siro pour une entreprise c'est
quelque chose de formidable et c'est
elle vraiment le catalyseur d'une belle
aventure qui j'espère va continuer à
chaque fois une application concrète
enfin tout à fait oui les mathématiques
mais il ya aussi la science comment
voilà il ya une effervescence de
laboratoire on pourrait dire au sein de
cette classe avec les enseignants les
oeuvres hebdomadairement lors de leur
rencontre à trouver un aussi haut
le sirop ce travail avec de l'eau donc
forcément il ya eu à un moment un cours
sur l'eau j'imagine oui c'est sur les
matériaux la conservation également tout
ce qui concerne
les plantes comment les conserver
puisque nous sommes allés une situe pour
découvrir le cassis enfin il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de dérivés et puis
d'applications possibles et l'autre
enjeu c'est quoi c'est l'orientation
c'est très important c'est un double
enjeu c'est déjà les beignets un petit
peu dans ce qui sera leur aventure plus
folle
c'est à dire de leur montrer que le
toutes les matières ont une implication
réelle et concrète leur faire penser dès
maintenant
et puis c'est aussi découvrir ces
métiers à travers donc une visite qui
sera dans l'entreprise crm très
prochainement d'accord donc vous
préparer ces visites j'imagine pour pour
mettre en place ce quoi le sirop de
demain le fameux sirop demain il va
vraiment sorti un coup marketing
non non on est très intéressé d'avoir
une cible en fait plus jeunes puisque
nous on a l'habitude de travailler avec
un peu plus d'adultes donc ça nous
intéresse d'avoir aussi de recueillir
l'opinion bain d'une cible plus jeune
donc on attend avec impatience au sein
d'entreprises dès la présentation des
élèves pour voir comment concrètement on
peut éventuellement appliquer certaines
choses pour nos innovations futures
ça veut dire qu'ils vont tester vont
goûter ils vont revenir c'est là tout à
fait non qui sont déjà mais une première
fois c'était courant novembre
ils vont revenir du coup au mois de
février la rencontre et les différentes
fonctions de l'entreprise et ils vont
nous présenter
donc nous on se rendra au collège de
nuits saint georges au mois d'avril pour
qu'il nous présente la synthèse de leurs
travaux
ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est le partage
qui a dans cette histoire la finalité on
l'a compris c'est faire un sirop oui oui
et c'est aussi faire découvrir les
entreprises locales parce que beaucoup
d'enfants connaissent les sirops vers
rennes mais beaucoup d'entre eux ne
savaient pas que se trouvait la société
se trouvait pas très loin du collège en
fait à qui l'on doit aussi le monde et
comme à l'arrivée mais finalement de les
métiers oui oui lé métier dans une
première visite que nous avions
organisée donc au sein du cassissium ils
ont découvert le malaxe les différents
types de cassis beaucoup beaucoup d'un
environnement va entrer très productif
pour le coup je me suis même laissé dire
que vous aviez une plantation de cassis
du côté du lit choristes que vous
représentez et vous
les envies emmenés sur place pour qu'il
découvre un petit peu tout ça tout à
fait donc en fait on a des plantes cas
ci c'est donc lors de cette visite les
enfants ont pu découvrir les différentes
variétés de cassis qui sont utilisées
pour produire du cassis mais comme vous
comme madame guignolée la signe
également la professeure de svt qui
était présente et qui ben va utiliser
enfin à utiliser cette cette rencontre
pour lors de son cours de biologie barre
vraiment expliquer concrètement comment
les plantes se reproduise a souhaité ces
sciences et vie de la terre c'est ça ça
n'a pas changé parce qu'avec les à
convenir sans indication nationale par
mais moi je n'y comprends plus rien à
part toi